[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue au
port marly pour cette seconde journée du
rendez vous de la jeunesse on est très
heureux de vous accueillir
je suis très heureux d'avoir à côté de
moi sophie gaugain secrétaire-générale
adjointe des républicains et
vice-président de la région normandie
notre collègue pierre henri dumont
député du pas de calais secrétaire
général adjoint en charge de la jeunesse
et on est chargé de vous réveiller ce
matin je sais que la soirée d'hier a été
pour certains un peu prolongé au delà
même de ce site
on était très heureux de vous avoir et
on est très heureux de vous avoir plus
d'un millier réunit aujourd'hui vous
pouvez vous applaudir parce que c'était
un défi qui n'était pas du tout gagné
d'avancé
vous savez ils ont été nombreux à nous
dire à christian jacob et et à nous
mêmes
il ya quelques semaines que nous
réussirions pas à relever ce défi de
réunir plus d'un millier de jeunes pour
travailler sur nos idées durant deux
journées et grâce à vous grâce à chacune
et chacun d'entre vous nous avons relevé
ce défi
non la droite républicaine n'est pas en
train de disparaître la droite
républicaine
les républicains sont en train de
renaître et vous grâce à vous nous
sommes en train de rebâtir cette grande
maison celle de nos valeurs celles
auxquelles nous croyons depuis de très
nombreuses années
sophie va vous parler de la journée
d'hier de ces ateliers de ces échanges
de ces débats qui nous ont redonné de la
force et pierre henry vous présentera le
programme de cette matinée qui nous
prolongera jusqu'à la fin d'après midi
avec une série de tables rondes aux
plénières auxquelles vous assisterez
toutes et tous dans cet amphithéâtre
merci merci aurélien pour l'énergie que
tu mets dans la réussite aux côtés de
toute l'équipe dirigeante rennie avec
christian pour ce rendez vous de la
jeunesse
j'ai été frappé hier par la liberté de
ton que nous avions voulu à chacune des
tables rondes reste est ce que vous êtes
soyez fière d'incarner les valeurs de
droite et au fur et à mesure de la
matinée continuer à porter vos valeurs a
aussi osé mettre sur la table des débats
et sur l'écologie nous y reviendrons
tout à l'heure qui vous interroge en
tant que citoyen votre engagement
politique c'est celui là c'est de vous
interroger
ça fait partie des valeurs des
républicains ça fait partie de notre
manière de faire de la politique et donc
continuons aujourd'hui
ce formidable débat d'idées je sais que
vous pouvez porter avec nous des
nouvelles constructions de politiques
publiques vous aurez de nombreux
intervenants vous êtes plus de 1000 vous
allez continuer à nous rejoindre tout au
long de cette journée
alors vive les républicains vive la
jeunesse de france
et merci de porter avec nous de
nombreuses idées je passe la parole à
pierre henri dumont qui fait partie de
cette équipe dirigeante qui met du peps
dans la façon dont ils apportent des
idées sur les responsabilités qui sont
les siennes et c'est parti pour une
longue série de débats et tapez 2 merci
à vous merci merci sophy merci aurélien
et merci surtout à vous tous réunis ce
matin je sais que l'aïe était un peu
compliquée pour beaucoup les murs de
l'hôtel on tremblait de vos pas jusqu'à
une heure avancée dans la nuit mais vous
êtes là vous êtes là et vous prouver que
on peut en effet de droite aujourd'hui
être jeune et les républicains sous
l'impulsion de christian jacob qui en
avait fait un de ses grands axes de
campagne sont aujourd'hui la seule
formation politique en france à pouvoir
rassembler mille jeunes depuis dix ans
c'est exceptionnel et ça c'est
uniquement grâce à vous grâce à votre
mobilisation partout dans les
territoires grâce aussi à la volonté de
l'équipe dirigeante qui a fait de la
jeunesse de votre implication au sein du
mouvement
l'acce majeur de son mandat et encore
une fois merci à vous d'être présent
aujourd'hui on a besoin de vous on a
besoin de vous hier vous avez été
nombreux dans les différents ateliers à
présenter vos idées à poser vos
questions à titiller aussi les
parlementaires les cadres du mouvement
qui était présent à vos côtés on a
encore besoin de vous continuer
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble de nos quatre
tables rondes qui auront lieu dès
maintenant la première jusqu'à jusqu'à
1h me lydienne médiane pardon de
l'après-midi alors le programme est très
simple le programme s'est tout d'abord à
10h30
la deuxième table ronde sur ré concilier
écologie et croissance avec aurélien
aurélien pradié qui est ici présents
damien abad le président du
à l'assemblée nationale florian delmas
qui est le directeur général du groupe
andros avec geoffroy back the cutting le
rdj des yvelines qui rapportera ce qui
s'est dit lors de la table ronde
on enchaînera à 11h45 toujours ici avec
la troisième table ronde réconciliée
démocratie autorités de l'état avec
virginie du binaire qui sera
l'animatrice de cette table ronde qui
est la vice-présidente du groupe à
l'assemblée qui est vice présidente du
parti et avec vous nos retailleau
président du groupe qui s'est dit alors
si vous avez suivi ce que je vous ai ce
que je vais vous dire il manque la
première table ronde et je n'ai pas
oublié c'est pour voir si vous suiviez
c'est surtout pour annoncer dès
maintenant que cette table ronde va
commencer et c'est pour ça que vous
demande d'accueillir sur scène agnès
evren qui va animer cette table ronde su
réconcilier europe et souveraineté pas
avec l françois-xavier bellamy le
président notre groupe ppe au parlement
européen et qu'un volume qu'en terre qui
la directrice de la fondation conrad
adenauer stiftung notre partenaire de
très longue date et élise des moulins
qui va venir rapporté ce qui s'est dit
hier dans l'atelier
merci à tous continuent à poser vos
questions si vous voulez poser une
question vous vous levez on va venir
vous apportez un micro perche est comme
ça ce sera encore plus interactif
continuez à vous deux à nous donner vos
idées continuer à faire entendre votre
voix la voix de la jeunesse de droite
est avec vous qu'on va tous ensemble
avancez vers les prochaines échéances
merci à tous
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à port-marly
c'est vrai que c'est assez
impressionnant
près de 1000 jeunes alors peut-être pas
mieux ce matin mais près de 1000 jeunes
un samedi matin à 9h ou cher christian
pour parler de l'europe et de la
souveraineté
honnêtement il n'y a que les
républicains qui peuvent faire ça merci
à tous de votre présence si nombreuse
ça fait plaisir parce qu'on se dit que
les jeunes veulent faire entendre leur
voix
voix et on est là pour vous écouter et
damman c'est un plaisir pour moi d'être
avec vous pour parler de ce sujet
d'abord en tant que députée européenne
évidemment mais aussi en tant que
président de la fédération des
républicains de paris parce que je
considère que vous êtes l'avenir de
l'europe
vous êtes vous allez avoir un rôle à
jouer dans le futur de l'union
européenne et c'est pour ça que on va
s'asseoir
votre avis nous est évidemment
extrêmement important mais je voudrais
mon cher christian puisque notre
président et l'a dit rossi devant annie
genevard et damien abad un petit mot de
politique quand même vous dire que on a
entendu des déclarations il faut
véritablement actuellement que nous ne
mettions pas notre drapeau dans la poche
il ne faut pas mettre notre drapeau dans
la poche parce que la france
la france a besoin de nos valeurs et de
nos convictions et si nous les
républicains ne nous des nous défendons
pas nos valeurs et nos convictions
alors elles seront reprises et en fait
tu trahis par d'autres et nous serons
mangés par les deux bouts et part en
marche et part en marche et par les
extrêmes et donc ne mettons pas nos
drapeaux dans la poche je le redis
devant christian soyons fiers de ce que
nous sommes et soyons nous-mêmes et
soyons nous mêmes
je le dis alors que nous parlons
d'europe nous avons la fierté d'avoir
des personnalités qui ont incarné notre
courant
le général de gaulle qui a fait l'europe
de la paix le général de gaulle
évidemment qui lui a fait la
réconciliation avec l'allemagne d'état
est un d'égal à égal et nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure donc je
voudrais avant que nous
lancions donc le clip où nous allons
entendre
antonio tajani qui est l'ancien
président du parlement européen vous
dire combien je suis heureuse de
débattre aujourd'hui avec vous avec à
mes côtés des personnalités absolument
remarquable françois-xavier bellamy que
vous connaissez tous et qu'un expert en
dehors d'être évidemment député européen
qui est un expert des questions
européennes et qui a des idées très
forte sur tout ce qui concerne la
souveraineté et qui donc ne fera pas
tout à l'heure de son point de vue et
répondra évidemment à vos questions nous
répondrons à vos questions pour l'avoir
côtoyé là depuis un an et demi je peux
vous dire que c'est un brillant
président de notre délégation au
parlement européen c'est un bosseur
acharné il mérite vos applaudissements
parce qu'on est très fier d'être
représenté par un tel chef de délégation
qui s'impliquent énormément dans les
sujets et qui actuellement est
rapporteur sur le plan de relance
européen et qui essayent de réorienter
ce plan qui est fondée sur l'emprunt et
donc il participe à toutes les
négociations avec beaucoup de conviction
et ça fait plaisir
je voudrais vous présenter également
qu'en terre merci infiniment de votre
présence
caroline kanter est actuellement la
directrice du bureau français de la
fondation konrad adenauer au sein de
laquelle vous avez donc fait une grande
partie de votre carrière
amérique du nord asie du sud-est italie
malte allemagne et maintenant la france
vous avez développé dans des activités
de la fondation à travers le monde
entier donc ce sera très intéressant
d'avoir vos positions sur la situation
actuelle et notamment sur les positions
de la cd ou sur l'europe et les défis
qui se posent aujourd'hui je vous
laisserai évidemment présenter votre
formation et toutes les conférences et
comment est ce que nos jeunes pourrait
également en profiter mais surtout ce
qui nous intéresse et le dialogue entre
la france et l'allemagne je vous
présente également élise que vous
connaissez tous maintenant qui est r dg
de la main et qui de façon extrêmement
sérieuse a participé aux tables rondes
on les a préparés voyez on a même noté
précisément tout ce qui a été dit pour
faire un bis
ensuite de ce qui a été dit mais avant
toute chose je voudrais je voudrais que
nous regardions tous ensemble antonio
tajani qui était donc l'ancien président
du parlement européen entre 2017 et 2019
parce qu'il a un message pour vous il
regrettait énormément de ne pas être
parmi nous mais il a tenu à vous faire
passer un message et donc on peut
l'écouter ensuite on commencera nos
échanges je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
chers amis républicains cher christian
cher françois xavier
cher arnaud malheureusement je peux être
avec vous aujourd'hui
quand j'aurai aimé à cause de la capan
électorale dans mon pays et de
référendum qu'il y aura les ventes 21 du
mois de septembre
moi je suis fortement engagée pour
essayer de donner un cours sescousse de
tremblements de terre aux gouvernements
de gauche mais je veux être avec vous
aujourd'hui pour discuter de ces
problèmes et blanc question l'europe les
différents pays membres
la solennité où est la limite des chutes
du pouvoir de chaque pays
moi je veux commencer avec les livres
les françois xavier
la demeure est ce que ma demeure votre
demeure et seulement votre pays c'est à
dire la france pour vous les allées pour
moi ole repos si moi je pense que ma
patrie et l'italie votre avis il y a eu
notre patrie commune la vôtre et de la
mienne qui s'appelle europe
mais alors où elle allie les gnons et
robin c'est pas super état
parmi nous
moi je crois dans la subsidiarité c'est
à dire chaque institution doit faire ce
qu'elle peut faire c'est à dire un
niveau local pour résoudre un problème
d'un citoyen mais si on doive pas mal et
après le niveau national mais quand il
faut faire face à la chine aux états
unis à la russie à l'inde
est-ce que ça suffit la france ou
l'italie
il faut avoir une force qui nous permet
de gagner les défis avec les autres pour
mieux défendre la liberté la liberté et
les valeurs
le plus important pour nous tous et les
intérêts d'aider chaque citoyen européen
mais il faut avoir aussi une europe plus
démocratique c'est à dire la voix des
citoyens européenne des chaque pays doit
arriver jusque au sommet de l'europe
c'est pas la bureaucratie qui doit gérer
parce que si la bureaucratie gère y aura
une réaction négative doit être la
politique
voilà pourquoi je pense qu'il faut
renforcer les rôles du parlement
européen les rôles des différents partis
politiques mme il y a une vraie identité
européenne qui sépare des 10 des luxes
éloize de 2,2 des fonctionnaires aux
deux de la bureaucratie
c'est la culture sont les valeurs c'est
le christianisme c'est la liberté
j'insiste les mots liberté il n'y a pas
une demeure s'il n'y a pas la liberté
il faut avoir une europe forte laisser
l'europe des diversités et la route doit
être l'unité des diversités donc un
grand merci pour l'invitation
la prochaine fois je serai avec vous
vive la france vive les républicains
divers mon pays et l'italie et vive
l'europe
un grand merci à vous tous et bon
travail
[Applaudissements]
merci antonio pour ces quelques mots qui
sont phase complète avec ce qui a été
dit hier parce que nous avons eu des
échanges extrêmement étayé très
réfléchie souvent très juste et souvent
je dois le dire très sévère très sévère
sur l'europe et ça rejoint un peu ce que
ce qui a été dit il il vous fera un
bilan mais je voudrais quand même à
titre personnel parce que j'ai noté les
phrases qui m'ont un peu frappé dans ce
qui a été dit vous dire ce que j'ai
retenu de nos travaux d'hier alors vous
êtes dans l'ensemble profondément
attachée à l'europe et c'est vrai qu'on
a senti un vrai sentiment d'appartenance
à l'europe
vous sentez citoyens européens c'est
vrai que vous avez vous vécu une europe
assez solide
vous avez connu toujours connu l'euro
finalement vous avez toujours connu
l'euro vous avez toujours connu les
facilités de l'espace schengen
vous avez aussi grâce à l'europe pu
avoir des smart des téléphones portables
ou des smartphones comme on dit qui vous
permettent depuis paris où depuis la
france de passer des coups de fil vers
l'europe sans dépassements de forfaits
sans dépassement de forfait
et puis vous êtes donc rendu compte qu
évidemment l'europe était utile l'europe
était utile elle existe elle est là mais
vous êtes aussi extrêmement critique
vous êtes extrêmement critique envers
l'union européenne et j'ai entendu des
reproches assez fort et je voudrais le
dire pour que vous les entendiez tous
ainsi que françois-xavier bellamy j'ai
percé une véritable déception est
certaine désillusion
j'ai entendu parler d'une replante
complexe qui apporte des réponses
souvent trop tardive d'une europe
technocratique très déconnecté du
quotidien des citoyens d'une europe
faible qui brade son leadership face aux
géants de la mondialisation totalement
dépassé par les chocs migratoire est
impuissante face aux menaces
sécuritaires et donc l'europe telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui n'est pas celle
que vous voulez grosso modo ce que vous
nous dites c'est que on est évidemment
pour l'europe mais pas pour n'importe
quelle europe
en fait c
simple vous ne voulez pas de l'europe du
président macron vous ne voulez pas de
cette vieille lune fédéralistes que nous
sert à tout va mc ren et son armée de
technocrates une europe sans frontières
et sans limite qui diluerait en fait
l'union dans une démondialisation
débridée et c'est le cas un équidé
posséderait le peuple français de sa
souveraineté alors qu'en effet la
question clef actuellement c'est comment
mieux maîtriser notre destin dans une
démondialisation dérégulé comme je le
disais et quand je dis notre destin je
décompose justement comme l'a fait
antonio tajani
je parle à la fois du destin de notre
patrie européenne mais aussi il faut
l'assumer du destin de nos patries
respectives vouloir une france forte et
c'est ce que j'ai entendu hier ce n'est
pas vouloir une europe faible donc ce
que vous avez dessiné hier c'était les
contours d'une europe puissante une
europe qui se protège et qui nous
protège mais dans le respect de
l'identité des nations qui la composent
vous êtes prononcé également pour une
europe qui soient réconciliés avec sa
souveraineté c'est au coeur de notre
débat ce matin qu'ils assument enfin la
défense de nos intérêts de nos emplois
de nos pme de nos valeurs évidemment
face aux géants de la médiane de la
mondialisation des réguliers mais aussi
des états unis de la chine des
puissances émergentes comme l'inde ou
encore le brésil
sur le plan économique bien évidemment
vous n'êtes pas contre le libre-échange
mais vous êtes pour le juste échange
vous est ainsi très favorables à l'idée
de double préférence il faut savoir et
ça c'est un chiffre qui est assez
marquant les taux d'ouverture des
marchés publics de l'union européenne
aux entreprises étrangères et de 95 % 95
% ce taux d'ouverture et de 32% pour les
etats-unis et pour la chine et pour la
chine et la russie 2 0% 2 0%
on en parlera tout à l'heure pour voir
comment est-ce qu'on peut justement
réformer les règles de la concurrence
européenne leur puissance est aussi
promouvoir avec force aux secteurs
stratégiques et donc nous parlerons
et vous confirmer également qu'il faut
donc transformer les règles européennes
de la concurrence pour permettre
justement que des champions européens et
enfin la capacité d'émerger et la
barrière écologique qui était d'ailleurs
une idée de françois xavier fait partie
fixe le dise la planète nuire les effets
de gaz des gaz à effet de serre et donc
de réduire notre consommation d'énergie
fossile et cette barrière écologique
était une excellente idée c'est une idée
que nous défendons évidemment parlement
européen et qui sera également mise en
place
j'en termine sur leur puissance pour
vous dire qu'en effet c'est celle qui
doit faire cesser le dumping tellement
sur les travailleurs détachés vous avez
dû en entendre parler mais à mon sens
encore beaucoup trop timidement leur
puissance et enfin une europe qui
protège ses frontières extérieures je
pense que françois-xavier carolina en
diront un mot et qui protège ses
citoyens des menaces terroristes
mais ce qu'a révélé la crise du coc vide
et qui vous a surtout interpellé c'est
le manque de solidarité et donc ce qui
serait intéressant aujourd'hui est ce
que je demande à nos intervenants qui
sont de grands spécialistes des
questions européennes
c'est que nous reviennent revenons sur
cette interrogation quelle europe
lapret qu'ovide du promet-il voilà donc
balayer un peu sommairement et
rapidement je m'en excuse mais nous
n'avons qu'une heure pour traiter tous
ces sujets un peu le ressenti de ce qui
a été dit hier mais encore une fois
c'était très intéressant parce que
c'était à la fois très clairvoyant et
est très sévère et donc comment est-ce
qu'on se projette dans une nouvelle
union européenne que vous souhaitez et
pas celle du président macron je
souhaite d'abord donné la parole à
carolina merci infiniment de votre
présence et vous dire donc voilà quel
est votre point de vue vous sur
l'actuelle europe quelles sont les
positions de la tse deus ça qui nous
intéresse également
ensuite je donnerai la parole à françois
xavier
et bien entendu elise dira ensuite sans
sa propre perception de ce qui a été
hier d'iai en tant que jeune
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
agnès c'est un grand plaisir pour moi
d'être avec vous ce matin bonjour
monsieur président jacques up
bonjour monsieur le député bellamy mais
c'était très important de discuter avec
vous la jeune génération des
républicains et je prends cet insigne et
très fort de la part du parti
les républicains vraiment mettre au
focus sur la discussion de cette année
la jeune génération
c'est très important ce matin j'ai vu je
ne sais pas si vous connaissez le
journal allemand frankfurter allegemeine
zeitung
ils ont publié un chiffre très important
les parties amont les partis politiques
allemands 1 pendant les 20 dernières
années ont perdu 50 % de ses membres non
et alors vous êtes le futur des
républicains français et je pense il ya
un travail à faire peut-être ici en
france mais je puis le dire pour
l'allemagne non les partis politiques et
les programmes à tiques sont très
importants comme vous pouvez bien sentir
le français n'est pas ma langue
maternelle et je veux m'excuser et
j'espère que vous avez un peu de
patience avec moi ce matin et peut-être
aussi un peu de gentillesse mais si on
parle de l'europe
c'est avec grand plaisir que je partage
un peu oui la perspective allemand et la
perspective de la télé où on commence à
bien expliquer la fondation konrad
adenauer et très proches au parti cd ou
aujourd'hui et je vais vous présenter
alors la perspective sur les thèmes les
conseillers europe et souveraineté et
mais d'abord encore une fois je voudrais
vous féliciter
vous vous gêne pas parce que vous êtes
impliqué dans la politique au niveau
différent au niveau local et régional et
nous savons des très bien que la
démocratie se construit au niveau
différent communales régionales
nationales et bien européenne et ça doit
fonctionner audible au niveau différent
parce que si on n'est pas fort au niveau
qu'on menait on ne peut pas réussir au
niveau national alors vous fait un très
bon travail et on travaille à mon avis
très entre temps j'ai eu la possibilité
hier
oui assisté ou de suivre un peu les
ateliers différents et ses terres une
discussion un très intéressant et je
voudrais remercier aussi ma nièce pour
cette compte rendu quelle affaire je
pense que je vais dire du ou 3m la
parole aujourd'hui opposition que
peut-être sont un peu divers non mais ça
c'est aussi normal en europe on a des
positions différents et ont discuté et
on s'est retrouvés oui un chemin qu'ont
communal à la fin je veux parler sur sur
trets points ce matin
d'un point de vue mm ont comme jeudi il
vole h
[Musique]
la première observation que je souhaite
faire et que cette discussion que vous
avez sous la souveraineté nationale nous
n'avons pas ces discussions en allemagne
allemand ça c'est le premier point que
me semble très important selon moi
l'europe et de l'intégration européenne
et la construction qui ont des coûts
elles ne sont pas incompatibles avec les
principes de souveraineté de point de
vue allemand je puis dire
je peux vous dire que la souveraineté
nationale ne va pas contre les intérêts
européenne et vice versa je pense on
peut dire que l'intérêt national
allemand dont la majorité correspondent
à les intérieurs intérêts européenne et
c'est pourquoi selon moi il serait
beaucoup plus constructif de penser la
souveraineté en termes de souveraineté
européenne les internationale pour
pouvoir être défendus dans un monde
globalisé et vous avez bien dit ça aussi
hier je pense passe par la plateforme
commune et ça c'est l'union européenne
en lisant nos objectifs au niveau
européenne en france les poids de l'onu
youn sur la chaîne internationale
merci carolina attention parce que il
nous reste encore à peine 30 minutes je
veux impérativement que le maximum de
jeunes puissent donc si vous voulez
comme ça on fera un petit échange ping
pong avec l'amiral ce sera plus
dynamique
ok est ce que le deuxième point qui me
semble quand même important que nous
nous avons un bien vu l'europe est
important dans la situation de crise non
il faut une idée dans en temps de crise
et à la fin grâce aussi à l'allemagne et
la france le couple un bon français a
bien fonctionné pour lancer un plan
européenne pour geste ir gérer la crise
son iter et on peut pas aller peut-être
sur les plans de relance un peu plus
tard les troisième point par doigts si
je n'échangerais pourrait développer
aussi dans les réponses vous inquiétez
pas on est là encore au qui se fait très
rapidement et ça c'est l'europe de l'est
n'ont pas d'accord du palais du couple
franco-allemand qui me semble dans le
contexte européenne très important mais
pour l'allemagne et pour l'union
européenne en général il faut aussi bien
regarder les pays de l'europe de l'est
ils ont d'autres défis à mon avis que
l'europe de l'ouest et il faut les
prendre important la liberté est très
important pourrait aussi le thème de la
sécurité que vous avez déjà discuté hier
et dans ce jour on peut voir que
l'europe de l'est a quand même un voisin
très agressif non et je prêt de la
russie actuellement et je pense qu'il
faut aussi donner un soutien à l'est ou
au pays de l'europe de l'est
pour finir la fondation konrad adenauer
nous avons des nous avons des des
bureaux dans le monde entier on peut
dire dont quatre dans 10 pays et notre
mission est de les dialogues le dialogue
entre les jeunes et le dialogue entre
les politiques et si vous êtes
disponible si vous êtes intéressés nous
sommes à votre votre disposition merci
beaucoup
sinon on va continuer pendant les
questions réponses je donne la parole
tout de suite à françois xavier pour 4
minutes afin que personne ne ressort de
cet amphithéâtre frustré de ne pas avoir
pu poser une question à françois xavier
je sais que tu sais faire c'est parti
c'est bon ça marche
génial d'abord merci infiniment de votre
présence merci agnès qu'est ce que c'est
bon de vous retrouver je suis très
heureux que nous soyons ensemble ce
matin et je voudrais dire un immense
merci à christian notre président à
aurélien à pierre henry qui ont organisé
cette journée parce que je crois que
très souvent on a mis les jeunes autour
de ce qui se passait dans les partis
politiques
aujourd'hui vous êtes le coeur parce que
vous êtes l'avenir et pas seulement
l'avenir
vous êtes aussi notre présent et c'est
par vous que nous pouvons continuer de
travailler
merci infiniment d'être là vous pouvez
être fiers parce que vous êtes la
fidélité vous incarnez la constance vous
montrer que la jeunesse connaît la
persévérance et je pense que dans la
difficulté
évidemment c'est toujours un moment
d'épreuve mais que lorsque nous aurons
traversé ces épreuves ensemble notre
unité n'en sera que plus forte pour
pouvoir servir la france c'est pour
pouvoir servir l'europe
je voudrais remercier aussi caroline
kanter d'être avec nous aujourd'hui vous
avez c'est très important pour nous de
cultiver ce dialogue avec nos amis de la
2 cv ou de la cs ou de la fondation
conrad adenauer en allemagne et dans le
temps dans toute l'europe et c'est le
premier message que je voulais faire
passer dans ces quatre minutes il me
reste encore trois le premier message
que je voulais vous faire passer c'est
soyez conscients que votre famille
politique qui traverse des difficultés
en france elle est aujourd'hui la
majorité européenne celle qui fait
l'europe aujourd'hui celle qui plus
exactement est en train de la refaire et
de la reconstruire bien sûr emmanuel
macron est président de la république et
c'est normal qu'ils aient des relations
avec angela merkel et nous le souhaitons
les plus efficaces possibles mais la cd
où est notre partenaire en allemagne et
c'est nous qui travaillons avec nos
collègues de la cdo tous les jours au
parlement européen comme au sein du
conseil pour pouvoir faire en sorte que
nous soyons capables de relever tous les
défis qui se présentent à nous vous êtes
la famille politique qui est capable de
faire l'europe aujourd'hui et dieu sait
qu'il y à du travail parce que nous
sommes dans un moment de crise profonde
tu le disais agnès aujourd'hui le
ressentiment est très grand envers
l'union européenne je suis rentré hier
de bruxelles
j'étais dans paris je suis alpaguer par
une personne dans la rue que je croise
qui me reconnaît qu'il me dit ah vous
êtes député européen l'europe a tout
raté
elle me dit c'est avec une amertume
tellement grande que je ne peux pas ne
pas entendre cette colère qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui et je crois que pour
entendre cette colère et pour y répondre
il faut prendre au sérieux cette grande
question de la souveraineté parce que
l'europe aujourd'hui elle veut dire pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens un sentiment
de dépossession l'impression de ne plus
avoir la main sur leur destin ce sont
tous ces agriculteurs cher question avec
lesquels nous travaillons
ce sont tous ceux que nous rencontrons
chaque jour je vois tous nos amis
parlementaires est ici et qui nous
disent que la politique européenne les a
dépossédés de leur capacité d'agir sur
leur avenir qu'ils se sentent
aujourd'hui démunis face à cette europe
qu'ils ne comprennent plus et je crois
que c'est là dessus que nous devons agir
alors peut-il y avoir une souveraineté
européenne et et c'est un débat
magnifique que que nous engageons au
fond sur cette question essentielle
cette question cruciale
moi il me semble que sur beaucoup de
sujets nous confondons en réalité
l'autonomie et la souveraineté et pardon
de reprendre ma casquette de prof de
philo un très court instant
évidemment c'est difficile nous sommes
samedi matin il est 9h30 mais vous êtes
la france qui se lève tôt comme aurait
dit nicolas sarkozy donc vous n'avez pas
peur du concept
l'autonomie c'est le fait de pouvoir
faire en sorte que sur des sujets
stratégiques nous ayons ce qu'il nous
faut pour pouvoir décider seul
l'autonomie c'est le fait que nous
devons pouvoir demain si une crise
sanitaire se présentait de nouveau
garantir que nos citoyens auront des
masques et des tests pour faire face à
cette crise l'autonomie c'est le fait
que si demain une crise alimentaire
traverser le monde et je sais christian
que tu es tellement attaché à cette
question et c'est absolument crucial que
nous puissions garantir que nous serons
capables de faire face avec une forme de
résilience que nous n'avons pas connu au
cours de la crise du coronavirus pendant
la crise du cours des violences tout le
monde a très bien vu que les pays
européens étaient démunis et que pour
pouvoir obtenir ce qui était le plus
indispensable simplement pour protéger
les citoyens européens
il fallait qu'ils aillent mendier en
chine les restes qui nous arrivait
d'asie et évidemment cela ne peut que
conduire
cela ne peut que conduire à des
divisions entre les pays européens et on
a connu ses divisions lorsque par
exemple le gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron à bloquer des masques à la
frontière entre la france et l'espagne
qui arrivait de suède pour les espagnols
au coeur de la pandémie
évidemment que ce sont des divisions qui
blessent profondément l'unité européenne
parce que lorsque nous n'avons pas les
moyens de faire face à nos besoins
vitaux la solidarité devient évidemment
un vain mot
l'autonomie c'est le coeur de la
politique que nous ayons défendre
l'autonomie stratégique européenne et je
sais que avec agnès et j'ai la grande
chance de travailler avec agnès au
parlement européen sur ces sujets là
parce que vous savez on s'est connu
pendant cette campagne que nous avons
mené ensemble que vous avez menées avec
nous et je peux vous dire que notre
unité n'a jamais fait défaut au sein de
la délégation française
nous travaillons d'une même voix dans
une même direction et notre direction
notre cap c'est cette autonomie
stratégique que nous cherchons à
défendre autonomie stratégique dans le
secteur de l'alimentation de la santé de
la défense du digital
c'est sur tous ces sujets là que
l'europe a vraiment un sens car personne
ne peut penser sérieusement que chacun
de nos pays isolément pourrait se doter
de cette capacité d'autonomie et alors
alors l'europe pourra servir nos
démocraties et nos souverainetés
car et c'est là sans doute que le débat
se trouve piégé en quelque sorte par les
mots je ne crois pas pour ma part qu'il
puisse y avoir une souveraineté
européenne c'est-à-dire une décision
européenne unique pour une raison très
simple mais je comprends que je
comprends que ce soit aussi une
discussion et je crois que c'est très
important d'entendre la diversité des
points de vue mais je crois que c'est
très important pour nous de clarifier le
sens des mots l'europe n'est pas un
empire
l'europe n'est pas un super état
l'europe n'est pas une seule démocratie
pourquoi parce qu'une démocratie suppose
un certain nombre de conditions de
possibilité et la première d'entre elles
c'est une culture commune c'est une
langue commune par exemple on ne peut
pas mener un débat démocratique
on peut pas mener un débat démocratique
par exemple pour le rendez vous de notre
élection présidentielle ou de nos
élections législatives
si l'on n'arrive pas à se comprendre si
l'on n'arrive pas à se parler je crois
que l'europe est un miracle démocratique
parce qu'elle est avec son modèle à elle
une alliance de démocratie qui
s'associent pour se renforcer dans la
mondialisation
elle n'est pas un seul espace unifié de
démocratie elle est un espace
démocratique parce qu'elle est une
alliance de démocratie et c'est ce
modèle là auquel nous tenons
l'europe n'est ni une sorte de
juxtaposition de petites nations isolés
qui se font la guerre les unes les
autres comme elle l'a été trop longtemps
elle n'est pas non plus comme les
etats-unis ou la chine un modèle presque
d'empyr qui
uniformiserait des populations
différentes derrière un rouleau
compresseur
elle est cette chance extraordinaire de
l'unité dans la diversité
et c'est là sa devise car nous sommes
différents et c'est extraordinaire de
voir au parlement européen à quel point
nous sommes différents par nos cultures
par nos manières de concevoir l'exercice
politique lui-même par nos langues
évidemment et aussi par nos références
historiques qui font de nous notre
conscience envers l'avenir et je crois
que il est absolument crucial de
protéger ce modèle de l'unité dans la
diversité pour que l'union européenne se
dote de l'autonomie stratégique qui
renforcera nos démocraties et qui
redonnera à nos concitoyens leur
capacité de maîtriser leur destin rompre
avec ce modèle fédéraliste en un sens
parce que c'est le nom qu'il a pris
rompre avec ce modèle qui nous a
conduits par exemple à l'illusion parce
que je crois que c'est une illusion de
cet emprunt européen qu emmanuel macron
a arraché de haute lutte il y a quelques
semaines pour pouvoir construire ce rêve
en quelque sorte d'un budget commun
européen et à terme peut-être des états
unis d'europe
rompre avec ce modèle qui n'a fait
qu'éloigner l'europe de la volonté des
citoyens s'est retrouvé le sens de ce
que l'europe est vraiment ça n'est pas
être eurosceptique s'est au contraire
être véritablement pro européen
c'est-à-dire fidèle à ce qu'est
l'histoire de l'europe une civilisation
qui a donné naissance à cette diversité
de cultures qui s'exprime dans une
pluralité de démocratie c'est cette
saveur la de l'europe c'est cette force
de l'europe qu'il nous faut retrouver
nous sommes à la croisée des chemins et
c'est votre famille politique qui écrira
avec nos amis de la de cdo et de toutes
nos familles politiques de la droite en
europe l'avenir de cette europe que nous
voulons pour lui redonner tout son sens
bravo françois xavier la main si
brillamment planter le décor est donc
maintenant place aux questions c'est sur
la première qu'elle n'a plus difficile
toutes les questions sont bonnes
être posée alors je vous en prie si vous
pouviez vous lever s'il vous plaît et
vous présenter avant de poser la
question merci beaucoup
alors donc je me présente matteo je suis
un militant dans la fédération de
l'indre et ma question s'adresse un peu
à vous tous mais particulièrement un
françois xavier weill
permettez-moi une légère et rapid
métaphore je pense que l'europe
aujourd'hui on a une voiture et on a
trois chemins on à l'europe le trajet
comprend est pas bon emmanuel macron
propose de continuer tout droit et
d'arriver dans un mur marine le pen ou
et partisans du fric site puisque l'on
sait pas exactement ce qu'elle propose
propose de sauter de la voiture en cours
de route je suis pas persuadé que ce
soit une meilleure idée alors finalement
quelle est la troisième voie que nous
nous avons porté pour conduire la
voiture dans un chemin qui serait
finalement un peu plus pérenne pour
l'union européenne et j'y viens le
général de gaulle je pense voulait une
europe unie des nations mais
certainement pas une europe des nations
unies alors comment concilier un emprunt
européen qui finalement peu une question
plus qu'une information que je pose cet
emprunt européen qui crée une sorte de
contrainte pour les pays qui l'ont signé
à rembourser et maintenir quand même une
souveraineté économique qui censé être
le coeur de notre pays
est ce que aujourd'hui on est dans une
europe des nations unies ou une europe
unie des nations la voici ma question
merci merci infiniment plus
moi vous savez alors c'est la chance
qu'on a et je voudrais remercier
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue là
christian mais aussi damien et bruno
parce que depuis le début de ce mandat
on a fait un travail très important pour
être unis au sein des républicains pour
parler d'une seule voix sur les sujets
européens ce qui nous a souvent coûté
cher dans notre famille politique c'est
les désaccords ou les divergences qui
pouvaient exister entre le travail que
faisaient nos élus au parlement européen
est celui qui se faisait ici en france
on a concerté notre position sur cette
question de l'emprunt européen et notre
position elle est résolument critique
pourquoi
d'abord c'est quand même toujours très
étonnant de s'enthousiasmer parce qu'on
a réussi à créer une nouvelle dette
malheureusement je crois que la france
avec emmanuel macron a réussi à exporter
à bruxelles les pires habitudes de
parier c'est à dire au fond que tout le
monde a applaudi debout parce qu'on
avait réussi à vous mettre sur le dos à
vous les jeunes de france et d'europe
on a réussi à vous mettre sur le dos un
échec de plus de la génération qui est
aujourd'hui aux responsabilités et de
fait cette dette a la particularité
qu'elle ne s'accompagne d'aucune
solution de remboursement c'est la
première fois que la commission
européenne va aller sur les marchés
emprunter 750 milliards d'euros personne
ne sait comment ils seront remboursés
on s'est soigneusement abstenue de se
mettre d'accord sur la question de
savoir comment on allait payer
ce qui veut dire en réalité qu'on vous
transfère le problème rassurez vous on
va essayer de faire en sorte de le
régler autant que possible cet emprunt
quelle est sa signification
l'idée c'est que pour la première fois
nous allons emprunter en commun et cette
solidarité
elle a pour but en réalité de créer par
la force des choses
à force du poignet une solidarité
budgétaire c'est-à-dire demain un
gouvernement budgétaire de l'union
au fond c'est toujours la même idée vous
avez dit non à une europe fédérale vous
lui avez dit non à l'occasion des
derniers scrutins
eh bien on va utiliser cette crise pour
pouvoir créer l'outil qui la fera
exister malgré votre choix
et moi je crois que la grande erreur et
ce qui conduira l'europe dans le mur
c'est de ne pas prendre en compte ce que
les citoyens ont dit ils ont dit qu'il
ne croyait pas à cette europe qui se
prendrait pour une sorte de super état
il ya une grande différence entre le
fait que nos états contribuent à une
action commune sur des sujets cruciaux
comme l'agriculture la défense
l'industrie
il ya une grande différence entre cette
europe qui s'engagent à travers nos
budgets nationaux sur des défis qui nous
sont
commun et une europe qui deviendrait à
travers une responsabilité budgétaire
une sorte d'état fédéral moi je ne crois
pas à cette solution
je sais que les français n'y croient pas
et je sais qu'on la leur fera pas
accepter même en la vendant comme une
solution à la crise du coronavirus que
nous sommes en train de traverser et
c'est l'occasion de notre travail
aujourd'hui
moi je suis donc le rapporteur au
parlement sur ce plan de relance je
fonde le coeur de mon travail sur vous
c'est de vous seulement que je parle
j'ai mis au centre de notre rapport un
critère fondamental que j'appelle la
clause du long terme pour faire en sorte
qu'au moins cet argent qui va être
dégagées ne servent qu'à une seule chose
investir dans des projets qui pourront
avoir une rentabilité future pour que
vous puissiez demain tirer parti de cet
emprunt qui aura été fait et y trouver
l'occasion de le rembourser et de faire
face à la charge que nous transférons je
crois que nous n'avons pas le droit et
c'est un c'est un impératif moral je me
permet d'employer ce terme
nous n'avons pas le droit de dépenser
cet argent issu de cet emprunt sur
lequel nous n'aurons pas eu notre mot à
dire que le conseil a décidé derrière
des portes closes en plein milieu de
l'été
nous n'avons pas le droit de dépenser
cet argent pour régler nos problèmes de
court terme pour tenter d'amortir le
choc immédiat pour la génération
présente parce que ce serait trahir la
génération future
nous avons le devoir au moins puisque
cet argent va être empruntés de
l'investir pour qu'ils puissent demain
permettre à la génération qui viendra et
aux dirigeants de demain c'est à dire
avoue d'assumer la charge de cette dette
que nous aurons transféré c'est notre
souci principal me ne pouvons pas
revenir sur cette décision
nous pouvons tout faire pour tenter de
limiter la portée de cette erreur et
nous ferons tout ce qui est possible
pour que vous gardiez à la marge de
manoeuvre nécessaire c'est-à-dire la
souveraineté qui doit être dans votre
main c'est une exigence démocratique
fondamental merci françois xavier alors
il nous reste encore 20 minutes je veux
le plus de questions possibles s'il vous
plaît les 3c court clair et concis à qui
la parole
allez-y on va vous tendre le micro ce
que tu disais françois-xavier sur le
plan de relance est valable aussi pour
la france parce qu'il n'y a aucun de
plan de financement des deux c'est 100
milliards personne ne sait alors on dit
ça va être remboursée par la croissance
alors certes il y aura 40 milliards de
livres on nous dit que les impôts ne
seront pas augmentés mais je demande à
voir
allez-y je m'appelle koh lanta catella
j'ai 20 ans et je suis un élu montilien
de montélimar du coup ma question est
simple je voudrais vous parler au sujet
de grands parle de souvent été on parle
souvent d'un territoire et donc comme
territoire schengen au niveau du
terrorisme c'est assurément seulement la
france qui assure la défense extérieure
de nos frontières en afrique et tout est
ce que vous pensez que une armée
européenne
c'était le voeu de emmanuel macron et
c'est un très vieux veut est possible ou
est-ce que c'est seulement l'otan qui
peut le garantir
sous bédié ou donc à réussir à nous dira
si elle veut ça c'est une incarnation
très concrète de cette question de la
souveraineté est ce qu'il peut y avoir
demain une armée européenne
vous avez raison le dire aujourd'hui
parfois nous sommes un peu la lanterne
rouge de l'europe et nous devons essayer
d'être à la hauteur de nos partenaires
et sur d'autres sujets c'est vrai que je
crois que nous avons le mérite français
nous français d'assumer une charge
importante pour le bien de toute l'union
européenne
et c'est vrai en particulier sur ces
questions de sécurité de défense
arnaud danjean est un grand spécialiste
de ces questions il n'est pas avec nous
aujourd'hui
mais il a beaucoup travaillé sur cette
question de l'armée européenne nous ne
croyons pas à une armée européenne c'est
une illusion et c'est une illusion
d'abord parce que nous avons des
cultures très différentes des cultures
militaires des cultures d'intervention
encore une fois nous ne sommes pas tous
le toute l'europe ne ressemble pas à la
france et quand emmanuel macron part
armée européenne il ne fait que rêver
bien souvent que ce soit la france en
plus grand c'est un réflexe finalement
assez nationaliste en un sens la france
a un modèle d'armée qui n'est pas du
tout le même que celui de l'allemagne
parce que nous avons des histoires
différentes parce que nous avons des
traditions militaires différente parce
que nous avons des visions différentes
aussi de la géopolitique
on le voit très bien aujourd'hui sur la
question de la turquie nous n'avons pas
la même vision de ce qui est en train de
se passer aujourd'hui en méditerranée
orientale et c'est en un sens normal que
nous puissions avoir des discussions
mais qui peut imaginer demain qu'avec
une telle diversité nous ayons une armée
commune avec une chaîne de commandement
commun avec quelqu'un qui enverrait des
soldats dans la décision la plus
difficile qui soit le président sarkozy
l'a souvent dit celle d'aller dans un
combat à la vie à la mort au fond cela
suppose aussi une responsabilité
démocratique fondamental et il n'y a pas
encore une fois des états unis d'europe
il n'y aura pas de président de toute
l'europe qui pourrait assumer cette
responsabilité démocratique parce que
nous sommes une alliance de démocratie
en revanche nous avons beaucoup à faire
et je suis aussi responsable parlement
sur ce sujet crucial
le fonds européen de défense ça pour le
coup c'est une avancée majeure
seillant nous pouvons nous donner les
moyens de cette autonomie stratégique en
matière d'industrie de défense
aujourd'hui vous le savez quand vous
achetez des produits par exemple à
l'industrie de défense américaine le
gouvernement américain vous interdit de
disposer de ces armements de ces
équipements
selon votre propre décision vous devez
en référé à la jurisprudence américaine
pour pouvoir engager des matériels
militaires ou bien pour pouvoir décider
par exemple d'exporter un produit
militaire qui serait développée en
france avec des composants américains
vous n'avez pas le choix de votre
stratégie d'exportation c'est à dire de
vos relations géopolitiques avec
d'autres pays du monde
c'est avec ça qu'il faut rompre les
américains sont nos amis mais ils ne
sont pas nos fusain et nous ne sommes
pas leurs vassaux et si nous voulons
rendre au monde le service de cet
équilibre que l'europe peut lui apporter
nous devons avoir notre autonomie sur
cette question stratégique de
l'industrie de défense est là pour le
coup nous avons beaucoup à faire en
commun et moi je regrette que l'iran
s'est engagé dans la voie de cet emprunt
commun et tout le monde a dit c'est un
grand pas en avant pour l'europe mais
pour obtenir cet emprunt commun on a
raboté beaucoup de programme
authentiquement européens et le fonds
européen de défense qui devait être de
13 milliards ne sera plus que de 7
milliards
c'est un début c'est un tout petit début
quand vous savez que les états unis
consacrent chaque année 300 milliards de
dollars à leur industrie de défense nous
allons faire un premier pas et j'espère
qu'il sera le plus utile possible
je ne crois pas à l'idée d'une armée
européenne mais je pense que nous
pouvons nous renforcer ensemble sur le
plan de la sécurité et de la défense
à travers une stratégie industrielle
commune qui construit aussi des visions
géopolitique partager et ça je crois que
c'est un pas en avant absolument
fondamental que nous pouvons faire
ensemble alors pas cher caroline
peut-être un point de vue de l'accès des
eaux
rapidement je pense qu'il faut bien
comprendre que les systèmes
parlementaires sont très différents dans
les pays européens et pour l'allemagne
il faut savoir il faut dire que la
chancelière ne peux pas m'engager la
bundeswehr dans un conflit militaire il
faut toujours la corde eu tellement
alors de créer une armée européenne sera
trop difficile aussi non et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on fasse vraiment atteint
attention il sait rien à mon avis de
créer des nouveaux organisations ou des
nouveaux institutions il faut bien
réformer les institutions qui existent
déjà
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose nous avons je pense tous
en tête plein d'exemples dans laquelle
les pays européennes n'ont été d'accord
homme solitaire et je pense avant de
créer des institutions
il faut se mettre d'accord sur le
contenu et il ya dix ans l'union leur
épopée européenne était un symbole un
rôle mais on peut dire pour autres
régions dans le monde et aujourd'hui je
pense on est très faible niveau des
points sécurisés et là il faut bien plus
dialoguer à mon ami merci parfait alors
à vous la parole
bonjour puis à l'aiguillon donc
républicain la mayenne juriste je suis
en cours de reprise d'entreprise donc
d'union européenne c'est quand même un
sujet assez important d'ailleurs je
tiens à vous remercier françois xavier
weill amis pour votre campagne aux
européennes qui a donné de la dignité
aux débats face à un jordan bardella qui
est fait dans l'invectivé face à une
gauche qui étaient dans dans le passé
donc merci beaucoup pour votre campagne
cependant on n'a pas fait un score qui
était à la hauteur peut-être des
exigences qu'on avait et donc je vais
revenir sur quelque chose c'est quand
même là il est peut-être le fondement
est peut-être la question centrale pour
les républicains de demain c'est de
savoir comment bâtir un programme au
niveau de l'europe qui va réussir à
parler au peuple parce qu'on voit dans
toute l'europe
le populisme les identitaires se
développe mais on peut les comprendre
ces personnes quand on voit par exemple
que le contrat pour les chaussures pour
l'armée française a été déléguée à
l'allemagne ces entreprises qui était
pas loin de maya mayenne c'est à vitré
qu on les faisait surtout sur est ce que
vous trouvez ça normal
si des emplois c'est des gens c'est des
familles et quelle confiance peuvent-ils
avoir dans l'europe
je reviens l'agriculture est ce que les
agriculteurs à avoir une vraie confiance
dans l'europe compte on va réglementer
la taille d'un camembert
quand on va payer il ya une
surréglementation peut-être à certains
niveaux
il ya une déconnexion réel de la
commission européenne du président de la
commission européenne souvent eux mêmes
par rapport au peuple et comment on peut
rattacher ce qui est l union de la
majorité populaire ce qui était un parti
d'une droite réel droit du peuple avec
l'europe qui pour beaucoup semble une
idée lointaine vaporeuse et merci
beaucoup alors françois-xavier comment
tenir un discours convaincant et plus
audible sur l'europe pour les
républicains
merci beaucoup la première chose c'est
je voudrais revenir sur ce que vous
disiez en commençant c'est vrai que
notre résultat aux européennes a été
décevant et
et pourtant avec un an de recul je peux
vous dire que je le dise droit dans les
yeux on aurait certainement pu faire
mieux on aurait dû faire mieux je lis le
premier parce que notre famille
politique m'avait confié cette mission
de mener notre liste mais malgré tout
avec le recul je suis fier de la
campagne qu'on a fait parce qu on a
parlé de tout ce qui est aujourd'hui en
jeu dans les institutions européennes et
d'une certaine manière vous savez je
pense qu'il ya une responsabilité dans
le jeu démocratique de chacun des
acteurs
si vous voulez tromper les électeurs
vous pouvez faire des victoires
éphémères
elles ne feront pas grandir la
démocratie et d'une certaine manière
c'est nous tous qui les perrons après
coup aujourd'hui je suis très étonné
d'entendre emmanuel macron reprendre mot
pour mot ce que nous disions pendant
toute la campagne
lorsqu'en pleine crise du corona virus
il va à la télévision est dédié aux
français déléguer à d'autres pays du
monde
le soin de produire notre alimentation
est de construire nos produits
industriels a été une folie le même
emmanuel macron qui disait en 2017 vous
en souvenez le protectionnisme c'est la
guerre je me dis qu'il a bien évolué et
que si dans cette espèce de souplesse
permanente il se met à dire la même
chose que ce que nous avons défendu tout
au long de notre campagne avec toute
notre famille politique c'est que sans
aucun doute nous étions dans le vrai et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois
je le redis avec agnès nous le voyons
tous les jours c'est nous qui sommes à
la manoeuvre pour essayer de faire en
sorte que deviennent une réalité cette
europe qui redonnera confiance aux
français vous avez totalement raison de
le dire
aujourd'hui nous sommes encore loin du
compte nous avons tant de chemin à faire
vous parliez de la question des
délocalisations d'une certaine manière
je dirais que si nous travaillons avec
nos amis allemands
si nous ne travaillons qu'avec nos amis
allemands nous en serions déjà très
heureux le problème c'est qu'en lire
encore au parlement européen en
commission de la pêche
je suis intervenu sur un accord de
commerce entre l'europe et la chine et
que j'ai signalé que même du point de
vue de la pêche puisque je suis en
particulier entre autres sujets dans
cette commission
même du point de vue de la pêche nous
voyons que la chine est le pays qui au
monde pratiquent le plus la pêche
illégale qu'elle immatriculent ces
bateaux avec des pavillons de
complaisance sur toutes les mers du
globe
nous voyons qu'elle traite mal les
pêcheurs qu'elle exploite en afrique en
asie
à tel point que certains meurent et
qu'on jette leur corps en mer nous le
savons tous ceux ci est documenté et que
nous sommes
train de signer un accord de commerce
avec la chine sans poser aucune de ces
questions
le représentant de la commission
européenne m'a répondu vous pouvez
regarder la vidéo elle est en ligne
c'est assez impressionnant il m'a
répondu écoutez monsieur lamy tout ce
que vous avez dit est vrai mais s'il
vous plaît ne l'écrivez pas dans le
rapport parce que nous avons besoin de
faire cet accord que voulez vous c'est
comme ça je crois que cette europe là
qu'ils se couchent cette europe qui
baissent les yeux cette europe qui
baisse la tête
cette europe qui oublie qu'elle est une
civilisation qui a des principes à
défendre cette europe qui oublie qu'elle
est la représentante de citoyens qui ont
des intérêts à défendre cette europe là
elle n'a pas d'avenir et moi je crois à
l'europe bien sûr je ne me sens pas
eurosceptiques
je crois plus que jamais que nous avons
besoin de nous renforcer dans la
mondialisation nous le voyons avec agnès
nous avons mené des combats et
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire encore une
fois à quel point nous l'avons vu
d'ailleurs aux élections municipales
aussi agnès est un modèle de ténacité et
je crois que cette vertu là c'est la
vertu dont nous avons besoin pour
pouvoir relever la tête
je me rappelle en particulier
je me rappelle en particulier d'un d'un
combat qu'on a mené au parlement
européen après un vote négatif en
commission qui faisait un très grand
problème à la france dans la commission
dont agnès est membre la commission des
affaires économiques et nous avons je le
dis très simplement mais c'est la vérité
nous avons avec nos équipes respectives
littéralement retourné le vote dans la
session plénière c'est cette ténacité
dont nous avons besoin alors évidemment
tout sujet est un combat tout sujet
impose une énergie immense mais je peux
vous assurer et en revenant sur ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure que ce lien
qui s'est créé entre nous pendant cette
campagne je donnerai tout pour que nous
puissions être à la hauteur de ce lien
que nous puissions être à la hauteur de
l'engagement exceptionnel que vous aviez
déployés et que dans quelques années
vous puissiez vous dire nous sommes
fiers de ce qui a été fait en notre nom
avec nos voix merci françois xavier pour
la puissance de son témoignage
je vous en prie très rapidement ma
génération seulement vous avez raison il
faut mieux expliquer l'europe et les
décisions européennes et on a on n'a pas
fait bien dans le passé les populistes
ont des réponses faciles non elle les
problèmes sont complexes et est
d'expliquer un problème complexe dans
une manière facile ça ne fonctionne pas
c'est la première chose c'est difficile
il faut
il faut il faut le faire non ça c'est
notre responsabilité compatit politique
aussi et pour l'allemagne et je peux
dire
dans le passé on a on a aussi fait des
erreurs si vous regardez les personnes
que nous avons envoyé à bruxelles
ce n'était pas les personnes très
connues en allemagne un nom qui n'ont
pas joué une rôle très important dont le
parti national et je prends ce matin
nous pouvons voir que vous avez deux
députées européennes qui sont très
présentes aussi ici en france ou en
france qui peuvent bien expliquer ce
qu'ils font un à bruxelles
et ça il faut faire non il faut avoir
cette communication au niveau au niveau
différent et mais vous vous avez pris et
déjà le bon chemin pour ça merci
beaucoup caroline alors une question
devant bonjour je m'appelle angeli je
suis étudiante en affaires publiques
préparation aux concours administratifs
je voulais simplement vous poser une
question un petit peu direct au sujet de
l' échange que vous avez eu au début
entre madame caroline kanter et et
xavier bellamy c'était assez édifiant
donc je trouve ça important de 2,2 le
relevé de poser le débat madame kanter a
parlé d'une adéquation parfaite entre la
souveraineté nationale allemande et la
souveraineté européenne alors que juste
après monsieur bellamy a soulevé la
différence entre la souveraineté
nationale française et la souveraineté
au sens large européen
voilà me vient simplement à l'esprit la
question suivante comment dans les
rapports de force entre nations au sein
de l'union européenne on parvient à
imposer son point de vue sur le respect
de la souveraineté nationale quand nos
partenaires principaux ne partage pas
forcément le moins le même point de vue
est également comment respecter ceux qui
ont une culture différente par exemple
les pays d'europe de l'est
voilà qui est intéressant votre question
françois xavier d'abord je le redis je
crois qu'en réalité ce débat est souvent
piéger par le sens même des mots et je
pense que quand on en vient au concret
voyez par mme si on parle de l'armée
européenne
en réalité nous avons la même
perspective il est clair qu'avec nos
amis allemands
moi je ne constate jamais deux
différences majeures sur cette question
dans nos débats au sein de notre groupe
ample au fond jamais nos amis allemands
n'ont pensé qu'il fallait dissoudre les
institutions de la constitution
allemande pour les noyer dans une sorte
de grand tour européen et ils savent
très bien et c'est la raison pour
laquelle encore une fois la cdo qui fait
partie de nos alliés partage avec nous
cette vision pour l'avenir de l'europe
nous savons très bien ce qu'est l'europe
ce qu'elle peut être ce qu'elle doit
être pour renforcer nos démocraties et
je peux témoigner d'ailleurs du fait que
ce qui me marque beaucoup chez nos amis
allemands c'est le sens très grand qui
l'ont de l'état de droit du respect des
institutions et je crois qu'ils ne font
pas partie de ceux qui s'aventureraient
dans des spéculations abstraite derrière
ce mot souveraineté
on entend trop souvent l'idée de cette
autonomie que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
je crois que c'est un problème de
vocabulaire mais quand on en vient au
concret en réalité nous sommes largement
sur la même ligne d'ailleurs pour
revenir sur ce que vous disiez
évidemment que c'est normal aussi
d'avoir des débats
évidemment c'est naturel à l'intérieur
d'une famille politique d'avoir des
désaccords parfois et je crois qu'on
peut dire que le ppe je vois notre ami
renaud qui est arrivé qui connaît ces
questions bien mieux que moi pour les
avoir pratiquées pendant longtemps le
ppe aussi est à la croisée des chemins
la droite est à la croisée des chemins
vous avez le sentiment d'être en
difficulté en france que notre famille
politique est en difficulté je voudrais
dire ça à pas pour vous rassurer
mais au moins pour vous consoler en
réalité cette difficulté elle est
partagée par beaucoup de familles
politiques de droite dans l'europe et en
particulier dans les pays fondateurs de
l'europe en espagne en italie on a vu
antonio tajani tout à l'heure qui est en
pleine campagne aujourd'hui est bien la
droite elle aussi est à la croisée des
chemins et nous devons au sein du ppe
c'est à dire au sein de la droite
européenne alimenter un vrai débat sur
notre avenir
le président de notre groupe
parlementaire manfred weber mam a confié
une mission et je partagerai ce travail
là avec christian avec vous tous
dans les semaines qui viendront celui
d'écrire un texte pour refonder
l'identité politique de la droite en
europe qui sommes nous qu'est ce que
nous avons à dire au monde de demain
qu'est ce que nous avons à dire aux
jeunes générations
il faut qu'on se pose ces questions là
et c'est ce que christian a fait avec
les ateliers de la delà de la
reconstruction qui ont été partagés au
cours des derniers mois avec ses forums
qui ont été organisées sur tous les
sujets on peut pas faire l'économie d'un
travail de fond
by intellectuelle et on peut pas ne pas
mettre sur la table les sujets de
désaccord je crois sur cette question de
la souveraineté n'ya pas tant de
désaccord que ça entre nous mais sur
beaucoup de questions oui c'est vrai
nous devons pouvoir assumer qu'il y a
des questions à se poser qu'il faut leur
apporter des réponses et ce travail là
moi je crois que nous ne devons pas le
regarder comme un problème mais au
contraire comme une occasion magnifique
de vivre aussi l'expérience démocratique
il ya une jubilation intellectuelle a
retrouvé y compris dans le fait d'être
parfois en désaccord et de pouvoir
confronter nos idées et d'en parler tous
ensemble et notre famille politique y
compris en france ne doit pas avoir peur
de ça c'est normal ça fait partie de la
vie politique est sûre si ça que nous
aimons si vous aimez la politique c'est
parce que vous aimez discuter débattre
dialoguer de défendre votre point de vue
comprendre celui de l'autre et à la fin
effectivement comme le disait carolina
l'instant trouver un chemin commun et
parce que je crois que c'est la dernière
réponse avant que caroline ne conclut je
voudrais remercier encore caroline
d'avoir été là parce que je crois que ce
débat il est vital en particulier entre
les français et les allemands
bien sûr aujourd'hui l'europe a beaucoup
de fractures à tenter de restaurer de
réparer la fracture entre l'europe de
l'ouest et l'europe de l'est et nous le
savons bien je le vois très directement
sur des sur des questions comme la place
de la hongrie dans le ppe ya justement
ce travail important à faire pour
pouvoir nous comprendre à nouveau
pouvoir nous parler à nouveau tout
simplement et j'essaye de le mener à la
mesure la fracture entre l'europe du
nord et l'europe du sud qui s'est
particulièrement exprimés dans la crise
que nous venons de traverser
mais tout s'est fracturé elles ne
pourront être résorbé que si la france
et l'allemagne parlent d'une seule voix
alors bien sûr ça doit être je le disais
tout à l'heure
vécue par nos gouvernements par nos
chefs d'état mais c'est aussi notre
travail comme parlementaire et c'est
notre travail comme famille politique
les républicains peuvent rendre à
l'europe le grand service de cultiver ce
lien avec la cd ou et de pouvoir faire
en sorte que à notre mesure dans notre
travail
le lien franco allemand continue de
vivre nous le savons le miracle de la
réconciliation franco allemande
c'est celui qui nous a apporté la paix
dont nous vivons aujourd'hui et je
voudrais dire à carling canter que c'est
pour nous une joie toujours renouvelé de
pouvoir partager cette conversation y
compris parfois lorsqu'elle est
l'occasion d'exprimer des nuances ou des
désaccords c'est toujours une joie pour
nous de partager cette conversation avec
nos amis allemands dans le désert
merci beaucoup et merci aussi pour cette
petite explication je voulais bien
expliquer aux souligner ce que j'ai
essayé de dire au début et que on a
manié actuellement nous n'avons pas
cette base de souveraineté nationale
non ça ne veut pas dire que la
souveraineté elles montrent ni pas
important aussi pour nous non ça c'était
le point que je voulais faire au début
et à la fin pour pour l'allemagne mais
pas seulement pour la télé ou aussi pour
les autres patty et nous voyons les
futures ' pour le bien-être de la
manière dont le contexte europe
européenne et seulement dans le coin un
contexte européenne et nous avons aussi
vu que les défis sont grands qu'ils ont
monté aussi merci dans ce conflit que
nous avons aussi avec les états unis
d'une part et la chine de l'autre pas si
on en europe mais pas ensemble
ça devient très très compliqué merci
beaucoup merci infiniment
alors il est 10h30 j'ai vu quelques
mains qui se leva je suis désolé si
certains louent repartir frustré si on a
une vraiment question pressante sinon je
voudrais qu'on donne la parole à élise
parce qu'elle est la futaie tous ces
arguments depuis une heure pour faire
cette conclusion parce qu'elle est le
rapporteur d'une autre table ronde est
elle a beaucoup travaillé
donc si personne ne repart alors allez-y
monsieur dernière question et ensuite je
laisse la parole à hélices pour conclure
mais il a une une question vraiment très
très très continent je vous couperet
parce que c'est lors de la seconde table
ronde
merci messieurs bellamy vous avez mis au
même rang l'alimentation les masques et
le
les solutions hydro alcooliques au début
de votre propos dans votre introduction
de mémoire en europe nous n'avons pas
manqué d'alimentation l'agriculture que
je suis déplore c'est pour ça que j'ai
crié tout à l'heure ah c'est vous et
c'est notamment grosse oui ben oui mais
on n'a pas manqué de nourriture il ya
des mouvements de panique dans les
supermarchés on n'a pas manqué de
nourriture et nous agriculteurs on est
quand même assez fier de ça en revanche
ce qu'il faut dire monsieur bel ami
c'est peut-être que justement si on n'a
pas manqué de nourriture c'est parce que
l'union européenne depuis 62 a soutenu
l'agriculture même si ça n'a quand même
très bien merci monsieur merci
infiniment vous savez on a droit d'être
en désaccord mais il faut toujours se
respecte et je remercie très rapidement
30 secondes pour les senneurs réalisent
qu'ils représentent toute cette jeunesse
et j'aimerais l'entendre on n'a
effectivement jamais manqué
d'alimentation grâce à vous et grâce au
travail exceptionnel que font nos
agriculteurs ja tirer juste l'attention
sur ce point et oui on peut les
applaudir bien sûr mais j'attire
simplement l'attention sur ce point
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons tous les yeux
rivés sur la crise sanitaire et nous
avons tous vu à quel point c'était
compliqué de faire face à une crise
sanitaire quand on n'avait pas les
moyens de protéger le concitoyen
n'oublions pas que demain la crise de
demain elle sera peut-être pas mais elle
sera certainement pas une crise
sanitaire
elle pourrait être une crise alimentaire
et à ce moment là on s'en voudrait
d'avoir abandonné la pac
on s'en voudrait d'avoir laissé baisser
le budget de la pac on s'en voudrait
d'avoir laisser produire par d'autres
l'alimentation dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui
à force de fragiliser l'agriculture
européenne et l'agriculture française en
particulier notre pays et christian le
répète souvent est devenue déficitaire
commercialement pour la première fois
dans sa balance commerciale agricole et
c'est un signal très grave parce que ça
veut dire que pour la première fois nous
avons besoin d'importer plus que nous
n'exportons sur le secteur de
l'alimentation
ce qui veut dire que si notre
agriculture est fragilisée demain si
nous ne savons plus produire en france
et en europe ce dont nous avons besoin
pour nourrir nos concitoyens nous
pourrions nous trouver demain tout aussi
démuni face à une crise alimentaire
mondiale
et c'est exactement pour cette raison là
que j'attirais l'attention sur ce sujet
c'est une question fondamentale
réapprendre à produire en europe ce dont
nous avons besoin c'est ce que nous
devons faire dans l'élan que nous donne
effectivement ce secteur agricole
français dont nous sommes tellement
fiers et qui nous montre qu'il est
possible aujourd'hui en france de
produire de cultiver d'exporter dans le
monde entier et de servir ainsi
l'alimentation de nos voisins bien
au-delà de l'europe d'ailleurs merci
encore voilà une belle conclusion
merci beaucoup réalisent voir d'égide la
marne à toi la parole merci beaucoup
gfr bref confusionnel cette fusion
l'europe et la souveraineté c'est une
grande question très vaste est également
complexe notamment au vu de la
définition des termes que ce soit
l'europe qu'est ce que l'europe
finalement une fédération confédération
vers l'état fédéral est également la
souveraineté est ce qu'on parle de du
privilège d'exercer la compétence de sa
compétence ou bien d'autonomie
d'indépendance europe les souverainetés
suppose deux pistes de réflexion d'un
côté l'union européenne face au monde
que l'union européenne soit forte sur la
scène internationale
mega est présente également le deuxième
rapport à savoir l'union européenne et
six états membres
est ce que l'état membre sont toujours
souverain est ce que la france est
toujours souveraine
cette question n'est pourtant pas
nouvelle nous l'avons vu récemment avec
la crise du coc vite 19 qui a mis en
exergue certaines failles de l'union
européenne face à l'état d'urgence
économique et social au cours de ces
deux jours nous sommes posé diverses
questions au regard de l'intégration de
l'immigration des politiques
commerciales industrielles sanitaire
également et peut relever également
plusieurs dysfonctionnements notamment
par rapport aux règles d'unanimité qu'on
a pu voir être le plan de relance mais
aussi face à une méconnaissance
peut-être globale de l'union européenne
de la population aujourd'hui
merci infiniment lise merci à françois
xavier merci la caroline merci pour vos
questions extrêmement pertinentes et
puis maintenant on laisse la place à la
seconde table ronde merci
et encore à tous et merci à christian
jacob de sa présence
damien abad eric ciotti aurélien pradié
puis henri dumont renaud muselier berger
du billère sophie gaugain merci à
bernard perrut gilles platret voilà je
cite ce que je vois et place à la
seconde table ronde